79 % -79 punto 1 - 58 y undécimo los
invito a pausar este vídeo e intentar
calcular esta expresión por su cuenta
bueno lo que llama la atención es que
estos números están en diferentes
formatos son representaciones diferentes
este es un porcentaje este es un decimal
y este un número mixto y para darle
sentido probablemente sea una buena idea
que todos tengan el mismo formato parece
que podríamos cambiar todo a un formato
decimal con bastante facilidad así que
hagamos eso 79% significa literalmente
79 por cada 100 si quisiéramos
escribirlo como una fracción sería 79
sobre 100 pero si quisiéramos escribirlo
como un decimal sería 79 centésimos
es decir 0.79 ahora 79.1 ya está escrito
como un decimal así que lo volveremos a
escribir
- 79.1 y luego 58 y undécimo bueno un
décimo es lo mismo que 0.1 así que
podríamos ver esto como 58.1 ahora que
están todos en el mismo formato hagamos
el cálculo lo primero que nos llama la
atención es que tenemos un número muy
pequeño aquí un número positivo menor
que 1 y le vamos a restar números
bastante grandes así que el resultado
será negativo para entender esto más
fácilmente lo que vamos a hacer es
factorizar un signo negativo y eso hará
que el cálculo al menos en mi cerebro
sea un poco más sencillo de modo que si
factor izamos un signo negativo déjenme
hacerlo de esta manera si factor izamos
un signo negativo esto se volverá
negativo esto positivo y esto positivo y
sólo para verificarlo imaginemos que
vamos a distribuir un menos uno menos
uno por esto es positivo menos uno por
esto es negativo y menos uno por esto es
negar
así que estas dos expresiones son
exactamente iguales
hicimos esto porque es más natural sumar
estos números y obtener un número
positivo mayor y luego restarle lo que
tenemos aquí entonces podemos usar
nuestro método tradicional aunque no
debemos olvidar este signo negativo que
tenemos aquí así que primero sumemos
79.1 + 58.1 79.1 + 58.1 un décimo más un
décimo es igual a 2 decimos
9 + 8 es 17 7 unidades y una decena una
decena más siete decenas es igual a 8
decenas más cinco decenas es igual a 13
decenas o 130 entonces tenemos 137.2 que
es esta parte que está justo aquí 137.2
y luego a eso le vamos a sumar 0.79
negativo que es equivalente a restar
0.79 entonces hagamos eso restamos 0.79
alineando nuestros puntos decimales para
restar desde el lugar correcto ahora
hagamos nuestra resta así que ahora no
estamos restando 9 a nada podríamos
escribir 0 justo aquí pero aún
enfrentamos un problema en el lugar de
las centésimas también le estamos
restando 7 décimas a dos décimas
entonces vamos a tener que reagrupar un
poco el numerador para restar o al menos
para restar utilizando la técnica más
tradicional
entonces tomemos una décima de estas dos
y más así que aquí nos queda una décima
y la otra décima se la damos a las
centésimas una décima son diez
centésimas podemos restar diez en
décimas menos nueve centésimas es igual
a una centésima ahora en el lugar de las
décimas no tenemos suficiente así que
tomamos una desde la posición de las
unidades esto se convierte en un seis y
este uno es igual a diez décimas
ahora tenemos once décimas once menos
siete es igual a cuatro ponemos nuestro
punto decimal seis menos cero es igual a
seis y luego bajamos este 13 fuera del
paréntesis todavía tenemos el signo
negativo cuando calculamos todo esto
dentro del paréntesis obtuvimos 136
punto 41 y no podemos olvidarnos del
signo negativo que tenemos aquí así que
todo esto es igual a menos 136 punto 41